I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense this is super common especially
in relationships where we react to
something were offended so we're like
well that was shitty and you're like
okay
Danica what was what were you really
feeling well what I was really feeling
was I was really feeling like I wasn't
important enough I was really feeling
like you didn't see me I was really
feeling like you were like you don't
love me enough for like you don't care
about me or like I'm not your most
primal i --q those that's really cuz
that's really what's gonna activate the
heart space and that's where you're
gonna get that's where you're gonna get
where you want to go with someone
whether it be a partner or a friend or
family when you peel the layers down to
the deepest one the vulnerable one where
you can go go ahead and judge me for
being was being wimpy go ahead and judge
me for being soft go ahead and judge me
for being sad and for crying and for all
these things but this is my truth and
but guess what if you can just practice
that vulnerability of going to a space
that feels really uncomfortable you're
gonna find somebody meet you there well
and like energy meets like energy yeah
so typically when we speak from our
space of vulnerability which is from our
heart not always but more than likely
when we're using those words from our
truth from the vulnerable space it
automatically activates their heart
space and if it doesn't that's okay you
just move on from that and sometimes
when I'm in a space and I'm having a
difficult conversation with my husband
it depends on where we're at and if it
and if whether it's me or him and if and
if if we're feeling a little bit of
resistance sometimes we just need to
take a break and then re address it when
we can step into that heart space
because the conversations that are not
met with the same energy right it's it
is like oil and what does kind of happen
sometimes it happens where somebody's
not ready to see not ready to hold space
for that emotion turn that happen
and that badly that's hurtful and that's
where you have to under you have there
has to be an understanding with your
family or your partner or your friends
where you say you have to try there has
to be an understanding that that emotion
needs to be honored right that deep sad
vulnerable emotion when you feel sad
about something when you feel you know
you'd if you'll not seen you feel
unimportant you feel you feel like
you're not listening to you feel like
you're not valuable or you're not a
priority whatever it may be that other
person needs to see that and honor that
mm-hmm
that's the only way you're ever gonna
keep that kind of conversation going is
when somebody looks at you and says I'm
so sorry to make you sad I don't want
you to be sad that was never what I was
intending and that's usually the answer
right but they they can't react to you
like that's ridiculous why are you even
why why do you even think that that's
not the space where you're going exactly
right where are you going to come
together so there has to be an
understanding with vulnerability with
whoever it's with that they have to
honor then right cuz then you're gonna
grow from there but you're never gonna
grow from a space where somebody is
judging right because they defending
right they actually they're not even
barely probably listening to your
vulnerability because it's not too quick
impossible to cannot connect with the
vulnerability because it's it's from
your heart
yeah it's they're thinking about the
other part of it still and the
vulnerability is something they're
they're not even listening to yet
they're not letting it resonate with
their heart they're just thinking like
but why are you mad it's so stupid it's
dumb why would you even get mad at that
why does that even matter you're making
a big deal out of nothing
they're still stuck on that so until you
can get someone to transition into the
end of the space of heart and feel an
emotion and vulnerability you're never
going to be on the same page so
sometimes that takes time sometimes that
takes and sometimes most of the time
communication doesn't always come
through words some people write it
better
some people need space I don't think
there's all kinds of ways where people
cope and like digest information
at different speeds - like I'm a I'm a
fast digester I'm like let's go let's
dive deep let's go
and I'm like why doesn't that why don't
you hear me wide and sometimes people
just need some time and they need their
own they need their own their own ways
right
[Music]